dans tout ça les travailleurs autonomes
sont frappés de plein fouet
québec a annoncé des solutions mais il
reste encore beaucoup de questions
on en parle avec myriam smir est ce soir
qui comptables fiscalistes qui travaille
particulièrement avec les travailleurs
autonomes bonsoir c'est quoi l'état de
la situation des travailleurs autonomes
et sport en fait je pense que le travail
autonome sans peut-être partie de la
population qui vend le plus en souffrir
actuellement le programme qui a été
proposé par le revenu par le
gouvernement du québec et ciblent
spécifiquement les gens qui ont
contracté le virus ou qui sait en
confinement pour supporter personne qui
est atteint du virus
ou encore quelqu'un qui revient de
l'étranger donc tous les travailleurs
autonomes qui se retrouvent sans revenu
parce que des clients sont en train de
fermer parce que les services qu'ils
rendent sont offerts à des entreprises
qui sont en train de fermer également à
ce moment là se retrouve dans une
situation où ils n'ont pas droit à
l'assurance chômage et il n'a également
pas le droit ou ou nouveau programme
d'ailleurs beaucoup de travailleurs
autonomes au québec
oui énormément et c'est ce qu'il faut se
rappeler c'est que la majorité ce sont
des gens qui sont soit dans le domaine
de la culture soit encore dans des
travailleurs autonomes qui ont trois
quatre clients qui sont également des
petites compagnies donc si on vit c'est
une chienne exactement donc si la petite
compagnie de 10 15 employés ferme
automatiquement travail autonome qui
fait une partie de design de choses
comme ça va également être impactés donc
faut être malade ou proche de quelqu'un
de malade finalement pour avoir droit au
soutien du gouvernement du québec ou des
temps confinement suite un retour de
l'étranger
exactement pour avoir droit à ce qu'on
appelle le programme des temporaires aux
travailleurs qui est annoncé hier cela
dit quelles sont les solutions
temporaires je présume qu'il ya des gens
qui nous écoutent qui disent bon ben je
reporte des dépenses qu'est-ce que je
peux faire
mais le plus gros des dépenses je dirais
ces hypothèques moi je conseillerais
tout le monde les voit les conditions
qu'ils ont dans leurs contrats
hypothécaires
il y a déjà deux bambins pas de banque
mais desjardins est une compagnie qui
s'appelle mkp qui ont déjà annoncé leurs
couleurs et qui ont décidé de le
et tout frais pour reporté des paiements
hypothécaires mais également que ça
n'aurait pas d'impact sur le crédit dont
je pense que c'est important d'aller
vers vous les les financières ou les
prêteurs hypothécaires pour voir si ce
report est possible dans les contrats en
cours
mais moi je m'attendrais ce que les
banques des instances financières en
boîte le poids de 6 aces soit comme des
jardins ou même 4 comme je disais pour
reporter oui donc il y aurait exactement
c'est ça il s'offre sans frais sans
pénalité et sans que ça touche le
dossier de crédit
on peut limiter les dépenses mais ça
devient complexe à un moment donné tu as
fait je pense qu'il ya un minimum des
dépenses qu'on est en en convoi à voir
de toute façon même si on réduit
certaines dépenses donc je pense que
l'idéal ce serait que le programme du ps
est soit un petit peu énergie et sur ce
point là je pense que le fédéral a dans
les annonces de demain pourrait nous
amener quelque chose sur la table étant
donné qu'on a parlé d' assurances impôts
élargi alors le pea tc le programme
d'être temporaires travaillant dont je
parlais et qui dont les modalités seront
disponibles à partir de jeudi là pour
aller assez vite mais c'est très
restrictif exactement ce qu il yad
autres allègements aux sources de revenu
pour les travailleurs autonomes
en fait je pense qu'ils travaillent
autonomes doivent également regarder
peut-être les clients qui travaille
peut-être pour essayer de rééquilibrer
les clients les plus à risque versus
d'autres donc essayer de rééquilibrer
avec des clients qui ne sont pas encore
fermés pour faire de travail chez ses
clients lors alors que d'autres qui sont
déjà fermés peut être reporté le travail
sinon je dirais que le genre de dépenses
qu'on pourrait limiter c'est tout ce qui
est remise
un paiement au niveau gouvernemental que
ce soit des impôts comment sait on à
reporter l'impôt aider le paiement des
impôts
il est vrai que les acomptes on n'a
peut-être pas reporter celui qui était
due cette semaine mais les prochain
acompte provisionnel vont être parts
égales celui du 15 mars puis quelqu'un
qui nous disait qui nous écrivaient
aujourd'hui 15 mars 2020 et du exact
oui y'a pas de congés la thune n'y a pas
eu de congé à moins que le gouvernement
fasse volte face mais effectivement
l'annoncé a été faite à partir du 17
donc malheureusement le paiement du 16
mars rester
en place rien d'annoncé encore
concernant le paiement de la tps et de
la tvq effectivement toutes les remises
de taxes ce soit pour le premier
trimestre ou pour les mots qu site a mis
le 31 mars 6 annonce l'homme n'ont pas
encore été effectués donc on
s'attendrait à ce que dans le soudan
l'annnonce de demain ou la semaine qui
est dans cette semaine que on remette
également la remise au minimum d montant
payable en vertu des taxes de vente que
pourraient faire les villes
effectivement c'est les taxes scolaires
et les taxes municipales surtout qu'on
pourrait peut-être voir à reporter le
paiement de la même façon qu hydro
québec annoncé que une certaine latitude
seraient prises pour éviter de couper
d'élèves dx des mesures extrêmes donc je
pense qu'effectivement les taxes
municipales pour et où les villes pour y
emboîté le pas avec les taxes mais
qu'est-ce que vous conseiller ce soir
aux travailleurs autonomes qui sont très
inquiet qui voile qui perdent des
contrats ou qui ne sont plus capables de
négocier des contrats je pense
qu'effectivement tous les travailleurs
autonomes on est vraiment entre deux
entre toutes les deux boules si on veut
le lait les grosses compagnies qui sont
en train de fermer et les traite un
homme qui eux doivent jongler la dent
donc je pense qu'il faut limiter au
maximum les dépenses reporter le plus
possible tout fait tout ce qui est
reportable discuter avec vos
institutions financières le plus
rapidement possible et également essayer
d'aller chercher les sous pour les
clients qui ont peut-être pas encore
plié
absolument myriam smir est merci merci
beaucoup